la conférence de presse de Lloyd Austin
le secrétaire américain la défense et de
Marc Millet chef d'état-major des armées
des Etats-Unis les deux hommes sont à
Bruxelles pour ce nouveau sommet de
l'OTAN en pleine guerre en Ukraine
contre du groupe de défense du groupe de
contact pour la défense de l'Ukraine
j'aimerais remercier monsieur le
ministre de la défense de l'Ukraine deux
nous avoir rejoint aujourd'hui
la semaine prochaine
le monde fêtera à sinistre anniversaire
cela fera un an que la Russie envahit
son paisible voisin l'Ukraine nos
pensées vont aux familles de tous les
soldats Ukrainiens qui ont été tués ou
blessés en se battant pour défendre leur
pays leur souveraineté et leurs
concitoyens nous
pleurons aussi les civils Ukrainiens qui
ont perdu des enfants des parents des
êtres chers car la Russie n'a cessé
d'attaquer des cibles civiles la Russie
a infligé une année de tragédie de
terreur à l'Ukraine
le peuple craignant néanmoins ont
inspiré le monde entier nous admirons
profondément la résilience du peuple
ukrainien votre détermination à défendre
votre territoire votre souveraineté et
votre liberté
les nations de bonne volonté se sont
ralliés pour contrer la vision de
Poutine celle d'un monde plongé dans le
chaos ou les pays peuvent violer les
lois militaires et attaquer leurs
voisins pour les envahir et c'est pour
ça que nous nous réunissons pour
soutenir l'Ukraine dans la commence de
son territoire à long terme
et nous agirons avec toute l'urgence qui
exige la situation plutôt ce mois-ci les
États-Unis ont annoncé une nouvelle
série de mesures d'assistance à
l'Ukraine il y a eu une annonce de plus
de missions pour des highmars de la part
du président
des
des armes automatiques entièresiennes
pour contrer les appareils iraniens et
russes des véhicules de combat
d'infanterie des munitions et d'autres
dispositifs clés pour la défense
ukrainienne nous avons aussi ajouté
1,7 milliards de dollars dans le fond
d'initiative pour l'assistance à la
sécurité des craignants pour les aider
renforcer leur défense entier aérienne
les deux temps de système de pointes
dans notre réunion d'aujourd'hui nous
avons retrouvé nos partenaires et alliés
pour nous assurer ensemble que l'Ukraine
a ce dont elle a besoin lorsqu'elle en a
besoin nous continuons à travailler tous
ensemble pour donner des capacités de
combat crédible à l'Ukraine il ne s'agit
pas que d'équipements c'est pour ça que
nous comptons synchroniser nos dons dans
un programme de formation coordonnées
vous voyez là nos efforts communs pour
répondre aux besoins de l'Ukraine leurs
besoins de char nous avons donné aux
défenseurs de l'Ukraine plus de 8
brigades de combat
des contributions majeures de la part
des États-Unis avec des véhicules
Strikers Bradley et des chars
[Musique]
inclus aussi le don britannique de
charts challenger et la
contribution de véhicules de combat
d'infanterie de la part du Canada
ainsi que des chars
T72 rénovée que la République tchèque et
d'autres pays vont livrer ainsi que le
don de la Pologne qui inclut aussi des
chartes et 72
ainsi que les étapes importantes
franchies par l'Allemagne la Pologne le
Canada le Portugal l'Espagne la Norvège
le Danemark et les Pays-Bas sur le
transfert de Charles léopard
nous avons aussi parlé aujourd'hui de
nouveaux dons de système antiériens de
la part de l'Italie et de la France qui
ont annoncé ensemble qu'il fournirait à
l'Ukraine qu'il leur fournira un système
d'arbre anti-riennes nous allons aussi
travailler avec l'Australie
pour fournir plus de munitions
d'artillerie 255 mm à l'Ukraine enfin
nous remercions l'Ukraine qui vient
d'annoncer quel fournira 7,5 milliards
d'euros en assistance militaire et
civile à l'Ukraine au cours des cinq
années à venir c'est un engagement de
poids toutes ces capacités continueront
à être importante pour le succès de
l'Ukraine sur le champ de bataille mais
comme je l'ai dit le mois dernier
aramstein il ne s'agit pas juste d'une
capacité en particulier il faut leur
donner tout le faisceau des capacités
que nous leur avons promis livrer tous
ces systèmes ensemble et travailler avec
les Ukrainiens pour les aider à se
battre pour leur liberté nous avons eu
une discussion importante aujourd'hui
concernant notre travail sur la
responsabilisation c'est une priorité
pour moi et pour mes collègues du groupe
de contacts pour s'assurer que nos dons
sont utilisés de la manière dont cette
attendue et que nous travaillons
ensemble pour empêcher la prolifération
d'armement nous continuerons à
travailler que nous partenaires du Kenya
pour nous assurer que tous les
équipements que nous fournissons
continuent d'atteindre les braves
combattants sur la ligne de front il y a
un an
Poutine s'attendait à envahir facilement
l'Ukraine
Poutine une partie du principe que Kev
allait tomber facilement et Poutine
s'attendait à ce que le monde reste sur
le banc de touche il s'est trompé sur
tous ses points
au cours de l'année passée les soldats
Ukrainiens se sont battus vaillamment
pour leur pays le peuple craignant a
fait preuve d'une profonde bravoure face
à la cruauté russe et les pays du monde
ce sont ralliés pour défendre les droits
et la liberté
nous voulons que les conflits dans le
monde soit résolu de manière paisible
avec un respect de la souveraineté et
que les frontières de chaque pays soient
honorés que les civils soient protégées
ce sont les valeurs de ce groupe de
contact nous sommes unis dans notre
soutien à l'Ukraine dans son combat pour
la liberté et nous serons Unis aussi
longtemps qu'il le faudra
et maintenant je donne la parole au
général merci secrétaire Austin merci
pour votre leadership dans cette 9e
rencontre du groupe de contacts c'est un
niveau d'effort très significatif par de
très nombreux pays et ça ne pourrait
avoir lieu sans le secrétaire Austin et
son leadership et d'abord je veux donner
mes condoléances au peuple de la Turquie
de la Syrie avec toute la souffrance et
les morts qui ont eu lieu en raison des
récentes tremblements de terre ceux qui
souffrent également ce sont les
Ukrainiens cela fait un an maintenant
de l'invasion illégale de la Russie elle
a envahi la nation souveraine qui est
l'Ukraine
et je veux remercier les ministres de la
Défense qui était présent ici
aujourd'hui
représentante 54 pays qui continuent à
participer à ce groupe
les actions de ces dirigeants au cours
de la dernière année
on contribué substantiellement avec de
vrais effets sur le champ de bataille
et ils ont collectivement contribué
fortement à la défense de l'Ukraine
je veux tout particulièrement remercier
le ministre restnikov le ministre de la
Défense ukrainien et son adjoint qui
continue de travailler
et mon collègue Charles sur le
champ de bataille tous les jours qui
mène la défense de son pays
dans 10 jours ce sera l'anniversaire
cela fera un an que la Russie a envahi
de manière illégale et brutale et sans
provocation l'Ukraine
comme cela était souligné à l'instant
Poutine pensait qu'il pouvait vaincre
rapidement en l'Ukraine fracturée l'OTAN
et agir avec impunité il s'est trompé
l'Ukraine reste un pays libre l'Ukraine
reste un pays indépendant l'OTAN n'a
jamais été aussi fort
et maintenant la Russie est un paria
dans le monde et le monde est inspiré
par la résilience et la bravoure de
l'Ukraine en bref la Russie a perdu elle
a perdu sur le plan stratégique sur le
plan opérationnel et sur le plan
tactique et il paye un prix énorme sur
le champagne mais jusqu'à ce que Poutine
finisse cette guerre qui la choisit la
communauté internationale continuera à
soutenir l'Ukraine lui fournir les
capacités dont elle a besoin pour se
défendre dans ce groupe nous soutenons
collectivement la capacité d'Ukraine à
défendre son territoire à protéger ses
citoyens et à libérer leur territoire
occupé
face à l'invasion barbare de la Russie
les Ukrainiens restent résilient la
nation ukrainienne est unie dans un but
unique
repousser les Russes de leur territoire
et défendre leur pays pour l'Ukraine ce
n'est pas une guerre d'accrétion c'est
une guerre défensive pour la Russie
c'est une guerre d'agression
l'armée russe a payé le prix fort de son
agression et maintenant ils en sont
réduit à envoyer des conscrits et des
prisonniers mourir sur le champ de
bataille
c'est dernier mois nous nous sommes
engagés au sein de ce groupe à fournir
de nouvelles capacités à l'Ukraine des
chars des munitions
des véhicules de combat d'infanterie des
munitions d'artillerie
et maintenant plus de défense entière
yen le groupe est focalisé pour fournir
les capacités nécessaires et pour former
les ukrainiens et leur fournir la
logistique nécessaire au déploiement de
ce système la formation l'entretien et
le soutien à l'Ukraine reste critique
pour que l'Ukraine l'emporte tout au
long de cette guerre l'Ukraine a fait
preuve d'inventivité dans leur capacités
à s'adapter aux dynamiques de ce champ
de bataille en flux
ils ont fait preuve de tactique
innovantes et leurs dirigeants ont grâce
à cela pu libérer le pays la Russie en
contraste mène un combat d'attrition
très coûteux tandis que l'Ukraine
utilise leur avantage asymétrique pour
se défendre et le plus important
avantage asymétrique qu'ils ont c'est le
courage la résilience et leurs
compétence tactiques cette guerre est
très dynamique et l'Ukraine aujourd'hui
se bat tout en s'entraînant et en
évoluant pour de futurs opérations
l'Ukraine a intégré nos ressentons de
véhicules de combat d'infanterie et de
char
pour des manœuvres synchronisées au sol
la Russie a continué cette guerre
pendant trop longtemps déjà elle ne
perdurera pas au-delà de résilience du
peuple ukrainien et de l'engagement de
ce groupe
nous avons un objectif politique clair
et simple nous allons protéger l'ordre
mondial basé sur le droit qui rejette le
droit du plus fort à attaquer de plus
petit pays les frontières ne changeront
pas simplement par l'application de la
force armée ce sont les principes
fondateurs des Nations Unies à la fin de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale
l'Ukraine n'est pas seul dans son combat
54 pays se sont rencontrés aujourd'hui
pour s'assurer que l'Ukraine puisse
continuer à se défendre et à défendre
les principes de la conduite de l'ordre
international et ses principes seront
protégés nous resterons une coalition
unie nous continuerons à protéger les
valeurs de souveraineté et de liberté
nous continuerons à soutenir l'Ukraine
et maintenant j'attends vos questions
secrétaire Austin vous avez dit plutôt
que c'est un moment crucial pour
l'Ukraine et que les Alliés ont besoin
de leur fournir des défenses anti-iennes
et des munitions spéciales maintenant
pourquoi est-ce que ce moment est
différent pour la Russie le secrétaire
général de l'automne nous a déjà averti
que l'Ukraine utilise les munitions plus
vite que les capacités de fournitures
des alliés est-ce que vous allez devoir
demander à l'Ukraine de faire plus avec
moi
est-ce que l'un des missiles tirés sur
l'objet du lac Huron a raté ça c'est une
question de domestique américaine
est-ce que vous avez pris en compte tous
les bons calculs pour abattre des
appareils au dessus du sol américain
est-ce que vous avez changé votre
approche pour les prochains objets que
vous détecterez si vous les détectez
alors concernant là où nous en sommes
pour le combat pour ce qui est du combat
ce qu'on a vu au cours des derniers mois
c'est une un champ de bataille très
contesté avec beaucoup d'activités
dans la zone de darkmouth c'est là que
la Russie focalise son effort de guerre
on voit que la Russie
introduit des nouvelles troupes sur le
champ de bataille nombre de ces troupes
sont mal entraînés et mal équipés
et donc leur leur taux leur taux de de
fatalité a été extrêmement fort
leur taux de perte a été extrêmement
forte ce que l'Ukraine veut faire dès
que possible cette crée
un élan
et créer des conditions sur le champ de
bataille qui continue à lui être
favorable
nous pensons donc
qu'ils conduiront une offensive
durant le printemps c'est pourquoi
tous les partenaires dans le groupe de
contacts de défense de l'Ukraine
travaille
travail d'arrache-pied pour s'assurer
qu'ils ont les capacités en termes de
blindés en termes de puissance de feu
soutenu pour être efficace pour créer
sur le champ de bataille les effets
recherchés
nous pensons qu'il y aura une fenêtre de
tir une occasion pour eux
de changer de continuer
de créer les conditions favorables sur
le champ de bataille pour eux en termes
de munitions ça a été un combat
difficile
l'Ukraine se bat depuis un an maintenant
et donc ils ont utilisé beaucoup de
munitions d'artillerie nous allons faire
tout ce qui est entre notre pouvoir
travaillant avec nos partenaires
internationaux pour s'assurer qu'ils
vont avoir autant de munitions que
possible aussi vite que possible
on fera tout ce qui est entre pouvoirs
pour que nos efforts dans ce domaine
soit soutenus nous travaillons avec les
soldats
Ukrainiens
un peu partout en Europe pour
les entraîner à de nouvelles manœuvres
nous nous focalisons sur les les
manœuvres les successions de manoeuvre
et de soutien d'artillerie et nous
pensons qu'à terme en se focalisant sur
les manœuvres ils auront besoin de moins
de munitions mais en attendant nous nous
assurons qu'ils aient tout ce dont ils
ont besoin et c'est sur ça qu'on se
focalise dans ce groupe de contact et on
pense que la formation des trop
ukrainienne paiera des dividendes très
intéressants alors
concernant les tirs sur le quatrième
ballon sur le sol au dessus du
territoire américain c'est celui qui a
été abattu au dessus du lac Huron donc
le premier c'est un ballon espion
chinois le premier a été abattu ensuite
le deuxième a été abattu dans l'Alaska
le troisième
a été abattu autre part et le quatrième
au-dessus du lacurant le premier tir à
rater le deuxième a touché donc le
premier objectif de l'armée américaine
c'est de protéger le peuple américain
donc nous évaluons le risque nous
évaluons le risque pose les ballons
est-ce que c'est une menace en terme de
renseignements en termes d'aviation
civile nous nous faisons très attention
à ces éléments nous calculons le champ
de débris
nous nous demandons où tout cela va
atterrir et donc on s'assure que
l'espace aérien et l'arrière-plan et
libérer en tout cas à la portée maximale
du missile et dans ce cas le missile qui
a raté atterri dans le lac Huron et on
s'est assuré bien sûr que l'espace
aérien était libre de tout trafic
commercial et civil on fait le même pour
l'espace maritime nous sommes très
précis dans notre planification nous
faisons très attention
au fait que s'étire soit effectué avec
toutes les mesures de sécurité
nécessaires pour protéger le peuple
américain
alors j'utilise le mot objet parce que
c'est le mot que tout le monde utilise
pour ces ballons nous n'avons pas
récupérer certains de ces ballons le
premier nous avons récupéré des pièces
et nous avons des éléments mais les
ballons 2 et 3 n'ont pas encore été
récupérés le terrain est très difficile
le deuxième a été abattu sur la côte de
l'Alaska
dans des terrains très complexes sur le
cercle arctique avec des températures
très basses moins 40
le deuxième est dans les montagnes les
montagnes Rocheuses du Colorado et le
troisième et dans le lac Huron
à quelques centaines de pieds de
profondeur donc ça va prendre un peu de
temps mais nous les récupérerons
nouvelle question
merci
et maintenant une question pour Monsieur
le Secrétaire
les jets ce qu'ils ont été fournis ou
non et quelles circonstances de sécurité
doivent être créées au sein de l'Ukraine
pour déployer des appareils de ce type
des chasseurs
est-ce que c'est possible après la
création d'un système de défense
antiériens intégré et pour le général
quel est votre évaluation des risques
concernant les routes
d'approvisionnement des livraisons
d'équipements
occidentales et de munitions à l'Ukraine
et comment pourrait-on améliorer la
sécurité de ces voies
d'approvisionnement
concernant les avions
je n'ai pas d'annonce à faire sur ce
point aujourd'hui
nous allons continuer à travailler avec
l'Ukraine aujourd'hui pour
faire face à leurs besoins les plus
pressants il prépare une offensive au
printemps dans quelques semaines et donc
on doit faire beaucoup de choses donc si
on réfléchit le nombre de systèmes les
bras de lait et les Strikers
les mardeurs
les CV 90 les 113
de l'artillerie c'est une longue liste
d'équipements et tous ces systèmes
doivent être
doivent être fournis on doit former les
troupes et on doit avoir une logistique
soutenue pour tous ces systèmes pour
qu'ils arrivent au combat donc c'est
vraiment ce sur quoi nous nous
focalisons aujourd'hui
sont toujours sujettes aux attaques
ennemis ce n'est pas différent dans ce
cas-ci
et nous pouvons faire face à des
attaques
ukrainiennes des attaques aériennes des
attaques d'artillerie la clé c'est donc
de s'assurer que les approvisionnements
parviennent sur place alors on prend
différentes mesures de sécurité on
change des parcours on change les
timings on a aussi des livraisons qui
sont dispersés on ne fait pas de gros
convois concentrés la sécurité à la
frontière polonaise ou tout autre
frontière fait par du plan de sécurité
des forces armées ukrainiennes et c'est
là qu'il récupère les équipements et ils
ont en place toutes les bonnes tactiques
alors le risque n'est pas zéro mais le
risque est modéré pour l'instant ça a
toujours réussi
une question de fin de chant times
merci
d'abord pour le secrétaire Austin on a
entendu dire par des responsables
occidentales que les forces aériennes
russes sont intactes et qu'ils vont
lancer des campagnes aériennes
maintenant que les forces au sol sont
épuisées quand est-ce que ces offensives
aériennes vont commencer et où est-ce
que nous avons fourni les bons
équipements antiériens à l'Ukraine pour
qu'elle soit prête à se défendre contre
cette offensive
et pour le général est-ce que la Russie
a le bon équipement pour menacer les
ukrainiens et faire une percée dans le
don-basse est-ce que l'Ukraine va
recevoir suffisamment d'équipements à
temps et avoir suffisamment de soldats
au sol pour mener une contre-offensive
merci
concernant la capacité de la Russie
concernant son accumulation de force
aérienne pour une attaque aérienne
massive ce n'est pas ce que nous
observons pour le moment nous savons que
la Russie a de très nombreux appareils
dans son inventaire et de nombreuses
capacités restantes c'est pour ça que
nous soulignons que nous devons faire
tout ce que nous pouvons
pour que jésus-chriniens est autant de
systèmes antiériens que possible et vous
l'avez vu récemment nous leur avons
offert des missiles patriotes d'autres
pays
leur ont fournit d'autres équipements ça
ne suffit pas et nous allons continuer à
souligner l'importance de leur fournir
plus d'équipement antiériens car c'est
une vraie menace
non de nombreux pays en tout cas on fait
des efforts notre effort à nous
actuellement c'est de nous assurer que
ses capacités parviennent dans le pays
aussi vite que possible et les intégrer
pour qu'il y ait vraiment une capacité
de défense anti-aérienne et
anti-missiles intégré l'Ukraine a fait
un travail exceptionnel lorsqu'il s'agit
d'intercepter beaucoup de requêtes et de
missiles lancées par la Russie dans ces
attaques récentes mais on veut s'assurer
qu'ils ont la capacité de se protéger
en cas de tentative par les Russes
d'impliquer leur force aérienne dans ce
combat ils ne l'ont pas fait pour le
moment parce que les défenses
antiériennes ukrainiennes ont été très
efficaces jusqu'ici alors concernant la
capacité des Russes à faire une percée
dans le donbassade ils attaquent dans le
Dombasle actuellement il tente c'est une
guerre d'attrition ils avancent
lentement ils ont
peu de morale et il progresse très
lentement mais ils ont les noms le
nombre avec eux
il y a des centaines de milliers de
nouvelles troupes qui arrivent sur le
champ de bataille donc ils ont le nombre
en leur faveur
mais leur réussite restent à être
déterminées le combat est en cours c'est
un combat d'attrition épuisant qui se
passent là-bas concernant les Ukrainiens
je ne veux pas me projeter spéculer sur
ce qu'il pourrait ou ne pourrait pas
faire
nous leur fournissons beaucoup de
capacités des capacités de manoeuvre au
sol etc ce qu'ils en feront ça ça sera
aux Ukrainiens dans des cités dans les
mois à venir
j'ai une question pour le secrétaire
Austin
concernant la position des États-Unis
pour les jets et le président Biden a
dit non pour la livraison de F16 lorsque
la Pologne a voulu livrer des miggs ils
ont les États-Unis les ont empêché
également est-ce que la position a
évolué sur ce point est-ce que vous
encouragez les pays à livrer des avions
où est-ce que vous pensez que le risque
est trop fort quelle est la position
américaine sur la livraison par d'autres
pays de d'appareils de combat
et pour le général l'offensive russe
qu'en pensez-vous jusqu'à présent est-ce
que c'est une offensive sérieuse est-ce
qu'elle est différente de ce qu'on a vu
par le passé
est-ce que vous avez des renseignements
concernant les tentatives des Russes de
nouvelles tentatives des Russes pour
capturer
merci Marcus alors
concernant tout appareil fourni pour la
fournie par la Pologne la l'Amérique n'a
jamais rien fait pour empêcher les
Polonais de fournir ses avions aux
Ukrainiens la décision de fournir ou non
ces avions
c'est une décision qui sera faite par
les dirigeants de ce pays ce n'est pas
quelque chose que nous dictons que nous
pouvons dicter concernant le fait que
nous allons fournir ou non des F16 comme
je l'ai dit à ce propos je n'ai pas je
n'ai rien à annoncer sur ce sujet et je
n'ai rien à ajouter à ce qu'a dit notre
président donc je réponde aurais
comme ça votre question et maintenant
concernant l'offensive russe cette
offensive qui est en cours à présent
dans la région de darkmouth
de Cardiff jusqu'à cardison la ligne de
front est stable même si elle est très
violente il y a beaucoup de combat c'est
une ligne très stable
la plupart des de la dynamique se trouve
autour de backmouth les Ukrainiens
tiennent
les Russes essentiellement le groupe
Wagner attack
mais je dirais que c'est
surtout un combat d'attrition avec des
pertes très fortes surtout du côté rue
il n'y a pas de grandes manœuvres ce
sont des attaques frontales des attaques
de vagues avec beaucoup d'artillerie et
à des niveaux de perte extrêmement
fortes dans la région le temps que ça
durera c'est très difficile à dire ça
fait des semaines que ça dure et je
pense que ça continuera
jusqu'à ce que les
russes abands abandonnent je ne pense
pas que les Ukrainiens vont reculer donc
je pense que ça continuera jusque là
c'est une bataille qu'on le regarde de
très près on s'assure que les Ukrainiens
ont les capacités de continuer à se
défendre concernant Kiev je ne vais pas
dire quel renseignement nous avons nous
n'avons pas je dirais que maintenant il
y a toujours une menace très claire
des missiles des menaces aériennes qui
ciblent la capitale ça de ce point de
vue là les capacités des Russes à
attaquer la capitale existe mais ils
utilisent pas autant et ceci conclut
notre session question-réponse